i'd like you to take a moment to think
about all the things in this life
that you will experience for the last
time
of course there will come a day when you
will die
and then everything will have been done
for the last time
but
long before you die
you will cease to have certain
experiences
experiences that you surely take for
granted now
if you're a parent
when is the last time
you will pick up your child
or tuck her into bed
or read her a story
our youngest daughter still says aminals
instead of animals
and though i'm a stickler for words
i am not correcting her
each one of those
is priceless
now thinking in this way lends a
poignancy to everything
even to things that you don't like
again let's say you're a new parent and
you're getting woken up several times a
night by your baby
that's brutal
but there will be a last time
and knowing that
can change your experience in the moment
there's something sweet even about this
experience
it's possible that you will miss this
we do everything a finite number of
times
and yet we tend to take even beautiful
moments for granted
and the rest of the time we're just
trying to get through stuff
you're just trying to get to the end of
whatever experience you're having
tim urban who writes this wonderful blog
titled wait but why
often touches this topic
he actually publishes a poster which
represents 90 years of life in weeks
each line has 52 squares and there are
90 lines on a single page
and the scale is frankly a little
alarming to contemplate
each week is a significant piece of 90
years
and you can put your finger on the
current week in your life
you can see where you are
and then of course you realize you have
no assurance of how many weeks you have
left
assuming that you have 90 years
certainly 90 good years
is generally not a safe assumption
what you can know however
is that each time you do something
pleasant or unpleasant
that is one last time you will do it
and there will come a time when you will
have done something
the final time
and you will rarely know when that is
for instance i used to love to ski and i
now haven't skied in well over a decade
will i ever ski again
i have no idea but i can assure you that
the last time i took off my skis
i was not even dimly aware of the
possibility that it might be the last
time
right that i might live for many many
more years and yet this stood a good
chance of being the last time i would
ever ski
when is the last time you swam in the
ocean
or went camping
when is the last time you took a walk
just to take a walk
as you go about your day today
consider
everything you're doing
is like this
everything
represents a finite opportunity
to savor your life
on some level everything is precious
and if it doesn't seem that way
i think you'll find that paying more
attention
can make it seem that way
attention
really is
your true source of wealth
even more than time
right because you can waste time
being distracted
so this is just to urge you to take a
little more care
when you meet someone for the first time
and you shake their hand
pay a little more attention
when you thank somebody for something
mean it a little more
connect with your life
and mindfulness is the tool that allows
you to do that
because the only alternative is to be
lost in thought
and every time you notice that you're
lost that you're distracted by a thought
about the past or the future
and you come back
you are training your mind
and it may feel like an effort at first
but eventually it's like continually
waking up from a dream
and ask yourself
how much effort
does that take
you are always meditating on something
your attention is always bound up in
something
we largely become what we pay attention
to
we are building our minds
in each moment
we're building habits and desires
and worries
and expectations
and prejudices
and insights
and mindfulness is just the ability to
notice this process with clarity and to
then prioritize
what you pay attention to
why not pay attention to those things
that make you a better person
why not free your attention from all of
the trivial things
that are clamoring for it
let's say you pick up your phone to
check your email and at that moment your
five-year-old daughter starts telling
you a story
now several things are possible
you could be so lost in your thoughts
about your email
and you could find the urge to respond
to it so compelling that you don't even
notice that your daughter is talking to
you or you could notice it only to
rebuff her in a way that makes her feel
terrible
and you might be so entranced that five
minutes later you wouldn't even recall
that this episode occurred that's how
most people live their lives
in fact that's how most of us live most
of our lives even after we learn to
meditate
but the more you train in this practice
the more degrees of freedom you'll find
in situations like this
you can notice for instance that your
daughter's trying to get your attention
and that giving her your attention
is in competition with your following
this urge to check your email
and when actual mindfulness comes online
you can feel the urge to check your
email as a pattern of energy in your
body
and simply let it go
that is you can actually break the link
between the feeling
and the behavioral imperative it seems
to communicate
it's true that one way to get rid of
this feeling is to check your email
but another is to simply let go of it
and only mindfulness allows you to do
the latter
and then you can direct your attention
to the five-year-old who is standing in
front of you and it might be the only
story she tells you that day
and you can be aware of this fact in
that moment
you can feel the poignancy of that
and in that moment you can further
ingrain this new habit
you can become the kind of person
who is fully present in moments like
that
and you become that kind of person
not just for yourself
by changing your brain
but in this case for your daughter
by changing her brain
and this is just a 30 second slice of
life
when you learn to meditate
there are literally hundreds
even thousands
of moments like this throughout the day
these are choice points that wouldn't
otherwise exist
these are paths taken and not taken
for good reason
but without free attention
there's no place for good reasons to
land
and as you grow in mindfulness you begin
to notice the lies you can no longer
tell
and you begin to have insights into your
true motives in various situations that
are sometimes not flattering
but you want these insights all the same
because how else could you become a
better person
that is what it is to live an examined
life
so
don't meditate just because it's good
for you
it's more important than that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
mm-hmm
do
you